- Well, Ella, congratulations
on the success of Dickinson.
You have a great American accent
in the show was that a lot
of practice was that hard.
- So one of my favorite things to do
as a child was to, well,
first off, I was just obsessed
with legally blonde and really
American culture as a whole.
And my favorite thing to do for my friends
or the thing I did to
make them laugh was to
pretend I was an American
woman at a nail salon.
So I'd be like, Oh my
God, I just broke a nail.
Do you, how do I fix it?
Do I get like, do I get the blush?
Do I get the Rouge?
Like, that was what I did.
- I, first of all, I love
- Excellent
- I know, but I love that
She said, I was obsessed
with American culture.
I loved legally blonde.
And I'm like, just so
you know, there's more
to us when you're going blonde,
you've got to dive deeper.
Ella, you've got to dive deeper
- In nail salons or becoming lawyers.
That was all you Americans did in my head.
- That's my favorite. All right.
Well, Ella, what's the most
interesting thing you've learned
about Emily Dickinson.
- I mean, I was really coming
to Emily Dickinson, a fresh
I didn't study her in school.
And so I think what I
have found so incredible
about working on this
show and studying her was
that she was this artist that
was completely misunderstood
in her own time.
And her poetry
to those who she sent it
to was heavily criticized.
And yet she still found the
confidence to make, I mean
literally thousands of poems without
without the validation of
like the outside world.
And I just find it
spectacular to see an artist
like that is so empowered and
ahead of her time in that way.
- Yeah. That's gotta be
like a dream role for an
actor to be able to
play some like, you know
especially being a woman
and playing a woman
like that back in the
day is that you're right.
It was a pioneer at that
point for, for women.
And I adore you.
I think you are so awesome.
I love that.
We are your first show.
You nailed the entrance and the interview
really do dive in deep.
I'm just saying there's
there's more to us than
legally blonde, just saying.
Hey, that's good.
This is great pop culture.
You dive right in there.
That's amazing.